[Musique]
honnêtement là mais souvenir le plus
marquant c'est la première tentative
d'avoir un rapport sexuel avec quelqu'un
ouais ça moines
[Musique]
et et j'ai senti que quelque chose
n'allait pas je ne me sentais pas
c'est une erreur car je n'ai pu en tirer
aucune satisfaction
en fait dans l'ensemble j'avais honte et
je n'arrive à rien
[Musique]
bref un ami je me suis rendu compte que
vraiment aimé en soit sûrs alors je
n'arrivais à rien parce que je n'avais
aucune envie d'avoir des rapports
sexuels ou en tant qu'homme
[Musique]
je m'appelle erika mitcham et je joue au
football américain féminin
je fais partie des origone hawks notre
équipement de la wf à la roumanie
football alliance c'est l'une des plus
grandes organisations de football
féminin du pays
chez les athlètes transgenres les femmes
transgenres devrait-elle participer aux
compétitions sportives
je suis persuadé que oui je suis
transgenre et c'est ce que je fais
qu'est ce qui frappe le mieux la paume
ou le point quand vous allez sur le
terrain
votre objectif n'est pas de giplait
quelqu'un
vous devez serrez vos sens doit et en
faire un point frappé dans son pull
visage
[Musique]
jouer pour la femme à côté de vous jouez
pour votre soeur qui porte le même
maillot que vous jouez pour le nom qui
est écrit sur votre maillot
ce soir erika sera d'abord un peu en
position de quarterbacks ensuite elle
fera un peu de running back et est
jouera probablement un peu de ce que
nous appelons les ouailles de receveurs
août à m
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
sans dire que j'ai un avantage dans le
jeu c'est tout simplement ridicule
oui je suis grande mais vous savez un
jour nous avons joué contre l'équipe de
seattle et il y avait une fille sur leur
ligne défensive qui m'a vraiment
terrorisée elle était plus grande que
moi plus haute que moi plus forte que
moi je suis très loin des meilleurs
quarterbacks de la ligne qui sont des
femmes qui n'explose
[Musique]
personnellement je la connais depuis
presque dix ans je la connaissais avant
même sa transition est oui erica est
très très intenses traditionnellement ce
n'est pas un sport féminin et beaucoup
de femmes ont du mal à se faire à cette
idée d'être agressive parce qu'elles
doivent rester féminine en même temps
donc avoir quelqu'un comme eric adam
l'équipe apporte beaucoup d'intensité
d'agressivité ça ravive l'équipe et
donne de l'énergie à tout le monde
autour d'elle je ne sais pas si c'est dû
à la transition pas mais elle a apporté
de la force physique au jeu
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
ta gueule théo sa gueule allez allez
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
on les a et jay oui bien joué
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
la première fois que je suis entré dans
le vestiaire j'étais avec mon équipe et
à vrai dire je ne me suis jamais sentie
mal à l'aise je ne me suis jamais
demandé ce qu'elle pensait de moi j'ai
pris la décision personnelle de ne pas
jouer avant de me faire opérer
c'était mon choix personnel
je ne dis pas que je ne soutiens pas les
femmes trop genre qui ne se font pas au
père insurgés
excuse quand j'avais 16 ans ma belle
mère m'a surpris portant ses vêtements
et mes parents réagi de manière beaucoup
trop excessive à mon sens
hbc thuir je suis devenue prisonnière
dans ma propre maison
les portes étaient fermées à clé on m'a
envoyé suivre une thérapie nié jeudi
téra pieds parce que pour moi ça a été
au fond une forme tous de thérapie de
conversion
je n'ai jamais aimé j'étais contente de
ce que je voyais au dessus de la taille
mais j'ai toujours eu honte de ce que je
voyais en bas j'avais l'impression que
je ne devais pas avoir saccagé même si
évidemment je suis né avec
je disais même à mes amis que
l'opération avait réglé ce que je
considérais être une malformation
congénitale actes
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
pour moi c'est quelque chose d'étrange
de différents mais nous allons tous
devoir nous y faire je ne comprends pas
[Musique]
j'ai commencé à jouer au football avant
ma transition c'était il ya environ 16
ans je suis passé du stade d'enfants qui
est arrivé sans avoir jamais joué au
football avec tous ces gars qui eux
avaient joué pendant des années un stade
où j'étais joueur titulaire deux fois
all star ça marchait très bien sache on
voit simon magnol star de l'adar saison
que j'ai joué
il y a beaucoup d'autographes là et mon
nom sur le dos et lamballe
c'est un jazz et c'est la première fois
que j'en ai eu un il s'inspire le all
star et du crime
et si on regarde les photos de mes
matches avant ma transition
j'étais bien plus imposant
[Musique]
autre effet secondaire de la prise de
l'austro jet et qu'on commence à prendre
des kilos à des endroits où on en avait
évidemment pas avant c'est à dire que
les 5 pouces comprend aussi du poids sur
les hanches les fesses levante tarmac
depuis ma transition j'ai des problèmes
de poids que je n'avais jamais
auparavant
quand je jouais au football auparavant
j'étais beaucoup plus endurante
j'étais plus fort je pouvais faire 40
pompe d'affilée ça ne posait aucun
problème
les développé couché les flexions des
biceps les pois avec lesquels je
m'entraînais c'est drôle à quel point
c'était différent de ce que je fais
maintenant
de mon point de vue lorsque vous êtes
passé par la transition vous devez vous
entraîner encore plus à cause de ce que
vous avez perdu
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
non ça va très bien a confié son nom il
s'agit pour moi d'avoir la possibilité
de concourir et pas d'y aller de dominer
tout le monde je sens quand je suis sur
le terrain que personne n'a une chance
de m'arrêter
et aussi je nuis aux gens à cause d'
avantage injuste j'abandonne
[Musique]
c'est oui on a perdu 42 à 0
aussi l'équipe les entraîneurs nous
n'avons pas le sentiment d'avoir perdu
chaque fille de cette équipe a mis tout
ce qu'elle avait sur le terrain
[Musique]
vous avez vu combien de filles ont été
sortis du terrain
[Musique]
coutu des pêcheurs je suis sous le coup
de l'émotion
j'adore jouer au football je ne parle
pas à cause de la défaite c'est parce
que la saison touche à sa fin cette
année mais j'aime le football c'est ma
passion je joue depuis que j'ai appris à
jouer
cette fille m'a dit que vous l'aviez
interviewé elle s'est approché de moi et
m'a parlé de l'interview en disant que
c'est important pour elle de faire
partie de ce que je fais cela résonne en
moi ce que vous faites les gars c'est
tellement important que vous soyez venu
[Musique]
je ne sais que dire de plus je vais vous
quittez maintenant excusez moi
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
erika a été la première personne à
m'accueillir pendant les sélections et à
ce moment là j'ai compris ce que j'avais
envie de faire
grâce à toi je suis resté
tu es la raison pour laquelle je donne
tout tu es ma soeur ma coéquipière est
ma meilleure amie
[Musique]
santé erika
l'une des choses les plus difficiles
quand on passe par la transition c'est
le sentiment d'appartenance choc parce
que quand on a une éducation très
stricte
un contexte religieux ou à la croche je
dirais même c'est que des experts ça on
ne peut pas s'exprimer facteurs de ce
qui pourrait vous arriver ensuite la
peinture
mais la famille qu'on choisit compte
autant pour moi à cause de ce qui m'est
arrivé dans ma famille et je vous suis
tellement reconnaissante de m'accepter
comme ça
[Musique]
quand nous nous sommes rencontrés j'ai
voulu lui faire comprendre que je ne
cherchais pas y aller c'est comme une
soeur pour moi maintenant
je vous aime les gars merci pour cette
incroyable saison
j'attends la prochaine avec impatience à
l'année prochaine à l'année prochaine
[Musique]
être transgenre est difficile en soit
avoir un moyen de s'évader et de se
sentir fier comme le sport c'est très
important
nous ne cherchons à nuire à personne ni
à dominer nous voulons simplement qu'on
nous accepte tel que nous sommes ce
qu'on ait confiance on est au complet
[Musique]